COLT MCANLIS: Google
Cloud Next 2017
has hosted a plethora of talks
detailing the future of cloud.
If you didn't get a chance to
check out Mete Atamel's talk,
"Running .NET on Google
Cloud," then stay tuned
because here's the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Historically,
.NET and Google Cloud Platform
haven't exactly
played well together.
COLT MCANLIS: The reasons
for this are complex,
and one of the
biggest challenges
has been around the language and
tooling not working very well
with scalable Linux VMs.
RETO MEIER: But--
COLT MCANLIS: Brace yourselves.
RETO MEIER: --that's
no longer the case.
COLT MCANLIS: Improved
Linux support for the .NET
environment has allowed the
framework to extend its reach.
And the availability of Windows
VMs on Google Compute Engine
opens doors for new
types of applications
to run on Google infrastructure.
See, the decision to run .NET
on GCP is no longer an issue
of features and support.
It's about choosing the best
cloud platform for your needs.
And when it comes
to .NET development,
GCP has some new features to
help you be more productive.
RETO MEIER: Let's
start by looking
at the libraries and tools.
We've provided a suite
of runtime libraries
that make it easy
for your application
to interface with the full
suite of GCP services.
That includes everything
from the Vision API,
Natural Speech API,
Authentication, and Datastore,
all available for your .NET app.
We're also providing Visual
Studio plugins and PowerShell
cmdlets to help you
manage your GCP resources
from within the tools you're
already using on a day
to day basis.
COLT MCANLIS: On the
compute side of things,
we've got support to boot
a VM with Windows on it.
But we also go further by
offering Google Cloud Launcher,
which gives you one quick
deployment to Windows servers
that come pre-installed
with things like ASP.NET
and the Google Cloud
Platform .NET libraries.
But if you've already done
that legwork yourself and are
running say, a container with
Windows and ASP.NET Core on it,
don't fret.
You can deploy that
with ease using
App Engine Flex environment or
our Kubernetes platform, Google
Container Engine.
And the best part
is that all of this
is running on Google's
infrastructure, which already
offers fast VM provisioning,
simple autoscaling,
and per minute billing,
not to mention access
to managed services like
BigTable, Datastore, Dataflow,
cloud storage, and
genomics processing.
RETO MEIER: GCP also
provides a federation
of tools and services
which make your deployments
production-ready.
The health check system
can monitor your instances,
and a fully expanded and
accessible orphaned IM system
allows you to control who and
what has access to everything.
And plus there's integration
to Stackdriver, which gives you
logging, reporting, tracing,
and monitoring of your cloud
service, right out of the box.
COLT MCANLIS: Check
out the recording
of Mete's full session to see a
bunch of cool demos of ASP.NET
running on Google Cloud.
And if you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of the playlist.
And don't forget the Next world
tour, which is coming soon
to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]